I've got some some terms on board that
this chapter starts with because the
author begins with some reflections
about how Islam has been perceived or
treated in the United States like it
says of all the major religious
traditions representative the United
States Islam is probably the one that
many Americans have the greatest
difficulty understanding and it's not
because it's inherently difficult to
understand or because of its complexity
oh there's you know like things are
religion quite a lot of complexity it
has to do with with other factors which
were exacerbated bless you bye bye 911
and by you know the reactions back and
forth about that but we're already there
you know that is part of American and
Western culture in general so like you
said a lot of Americans have been
accustomed to think about religion in
winkled binary terms so you guys are all
familiar with binary code off on 01 any
computer science majors in here no is
but not computer science exactly but you
know yeah everyone gets the basic
conception and when you have binary
things that you know it's a black wipe
off on good bad and he talks about this
category of the other and the other in
American history has has changed as
people became part of the mainstream a
part of the consensus so originally
Catholic were you know the other for
Protestants here in the United States
you know you look at the Puritans they
really didn't like the Church of England
but they really didn't like the Church
of England because it looked too
like the Catholic Church which was going
to attempt to impose you know some sort
of theocracy upon them so they thought
their own theocracy as a response to
that and you know as different
Protestants denominations became part of
the the consensus in America first it
was Catholics and that it was Mormons
Jews were sort of perennial other
category but they actually buy you know
the 1950s as far as Catholics and Jews
were concerned became part of the
consensus we've looked at that story so
now you know somebody very good
Catholics do this anymore but somebody
crosses themselves and says grace before
meals you know nobody's going to drop
the salt and say oh my god Catholics are
here Islam is is in a different stage as
far as that so Islam has become sort of
the other part excellence and he brings
up a very popular social theorist Edward
Syed who talks about orientalism
orientalism is this this attitude that
he discerns in in the West and we're
America was part of the west which sort
of displaces everything that's dangerous
or irrational on to the east to orient
and use the word Orientalism because
you're not supposed to use for dental
anymore he knows it's a non PC term and
like you said like the book notes these
negative or ambiguous associations with
the Orient have been reinforced by areas
to hostile acts you know disruption of
an Olympics air hijackings the Iranian
Revolution and the hostage crisis which
occurred when I was a kid I remember
what a huge effect that he had on
Americans out the Midwest even you know
know anybody there you know I felt sort
of viscerally affected by it and he
points out that there's two things
important to keep in mind one is that
the sort of other dancer if we want to
use a technical term for this in
religious studies and philosophy
alterity this altera t is different than
that evoke by Hindus or Buddhists or
other you know quote non-western
religions in part because Islam is a
Western religions it is you know from
the same sort of group in stock as
Judaism and Christianity it's coming
from the Middle East which is where all
three of those religions originated it
has a lot in common with them much more
than safe Buddhism or Hinduism or if we
want to pick other you know as they want
them into this category Eastern
religions like Taoism Confucianism have
and so oftentimes you know what we see
is what he calls the invoking Freud the
narcissism of small differences it's in
part because Islam is historically so
close to Christianity and Judaism that
it can seem at other time so distant
interestingly when Islam first came on
the scene it wasn't recognized by by
most Christians as being a religion they
just thought oh this is another Arian
heresy for centuries many of them
thought that and that came to be
recognized as as it's you know only
separate sort of thing the other thing
that he points out is who do we tend to
associate Islam with here in the United
States what ethnicity yeah yeah and I
mean there are some reasons to associate
Arab ethnicity with Islam for example
the Quran is written
arabic the hadith are written in the
arabic you know many of the important
legal schools carried out over their
writings in Arabic but are Arabs the
majority of Muslims worldwide no but you
know the largest Muslim country is
actually by if i remember right it
indonesia and our arabs the majority of
Muslims in the United States no as a
matter of fact the majority of errands
in the united states are actually
christians you know maronite Catholics
would be an example of them Assyrian
Church of the east not exactly Arabic
but they get lumped into the same
category so those are all things to keep
in mind now he talks about I won't put
all these up on the board he talks about
Islam in terms of six elements of faith
and then the five pillars will put the
five pillars up the moment but the six
elements of faith would be mounting a
radical monotheism there is no god but
but God a lot of laws the Arabic word
for God angels God's message to humanity
contained in a book of the Quran the
Prophet Muhammad being the the last of
the prophets the seal as they say of the
prophets a resurrection and judgment at
the end of time in all human events
being being shaped by measuring out by
some sort of providential ordering of
human affairs now what did this sounds
radically different than there's a good
compare and contrast what are this
sounds radically different from Judaism
officiality where the sticking points is
it the monotheism well for you know
Muslims with the Trinity that most
Christians want
doors but most Christians have some sort
of take on the Trinity where although
God is three God is also still one right
is it the notion of angels the Jews and
Christians not believe in angels may the
liberal you know ones who want to
explain everything in terms of culture
or things like that they may not believe
in them but most traditional Jews and
Christians do what about the notion of
God revealing things communities is that
a problem not really the book which book
is that that would be one of the
sticking points right Christians do you
not see too many of them reading the
Quran interesting they want to might one
of my copies of it the one at the Arabic
on one side and English on the other I
got from a priest who was spending his
time studying it the Prophet Muhammad
okay that's that's going to be a
divisive thing because you know he's
coming later but you know Muhammad is
seen by Muslims as being the last of the
whole succession of profits of people
come in to speak what about the notion
of Resurrection or judgment is that is
that a major issue for most Jews and
Christians they kind of insist on that
don't they think about the Nicene Creed
I believe in the XYZ comes towards the
end resurrection of the dad I guess they
they all have that in common so let's
look at the five pillars because this is
something where we have a bit more
distinctiveness so the first pillar is
what you can call the Johanna or creedal
statement there is no god but but a lot
it's a reaffirmation of monotheism of
rat
monotheism implicit in that we go that
one ought not to engage in idolatry or
for sure making something else God you
know this will be a really silly
instance but let's say I was like a
super super coffee kind of sewer you
know if I was I wouldn't be doing
Starbucks because their coffee isn't
great but let's say it was right and I
bow down and worship this well that
would be idolatry you know it would be
doing something which is not in itself
day odd because you know there is a
right object for God but it would be
doing something towards not God or what
if I did that towards myself the self
the center of the universe there would
be a problem as well Salah which is
original prayer five times daily there's
actually interesting discussions about
why five times you know that you know
you can if you want to go into
literature you can find some of those
discuss the idea is that one watch you
bring God to my five times at least
ideally one does it more often come
happen five times at least during during
the day one shows ones submission to the
Divine Will and this takes place
individually it also takes place
communally through through the services
in a masjid mosque almsgiving or what's
another word that we use are at all it's
getting we don't we don't often go
around and say would you like to give
some alms yeah yeah and what do we call
that more often these days exact charity
is a good translation of
and in some Muslim countries is just
done by tax you're living there you on
that the pay it's not an issue here in
the United States Muslims would do this
in large part by instead of walking
around just you know doling out money to
somebody on the street you give it to an
Islamic charity sort of like you know if
you're in a sort of American office
sooner or later somebody's going to hit
you up for the united way or some other
thing like that well there's Muslim
charities out there that do things like
provide relief in Muslim countries for
earthquakes for political instability
that result some refugees things like
that what else fasting fasting during
the month of Ramadan the and fasting is
pretty hardcore when I when I taught in
Indiana State Prison I you know some of
my students were actually Sunni Muslims
and it was really tough for them because
the fast means nothing goes into your
mouth nothing passes through through the
lips no water no food not gum know what
you don't know tobacco of course so from
sunup to sundown nothing and one sunday
comes around sometimes you're locked
into your cell and you can't get you
know too much of anything anyway so for
quite a few of these guys it was quite a
her shock there's interesting issues
that have come up you know like about
NBA players who as Muslims do they
observe the the fast even though it's
going to be kind of tough on the body
imagine playing you know a hardcore
sport and you can't take a sip of your
your water bottle until after sundown
yeah I have all night games a problem
right but it can be put off you know in
case of somebody being sick or being a
traveling or at war but it has to be
made up later on and part of this is to
a cert discipline over the bottom this
sort of
asceticism is common in many religious
traditions Christian Christian monastics
would engage in fasting Catholics
Eastern Orthodox the other you some
Christians at least on paper still fast
during certain periods of the year like
for example lens for Catholics that
actually made it so easy that it's
almost naturally fast but in the old
days one would fast olive lens want to
reduce what's intake of things and the
Ramadan is seen is a particularly
propitious time for spiritual
development and prayer then finally
we've talked about this before remember
when we talked about Malcolm X the
pilgrim [ __ ] alhaj one should go to
Mecca in a neely to some of the other
holy cities as well and trace out the
path that the the Prophet Muhammad who's
mr. like the ideal human being that's
why they they do you know they're
interested in what he had to say one
goes and does this as part of a communal
experience and it involves you know at
high times you know literally millions
of people are involved in this
pilgrimage ultimately culminating it
swirling around the kebabs is central
stone now your book also talks about
jihad that's something that's that's
important to think about and you'll get
two different sort of takes on this both
of which are equally wrong by quite a
few people because they're
oversimplifications one is jihad means
holy war so every Muslim is supposed to
be carrying out war on the infidel or
the unbeliever clearly that's not the
case although some people you know
interpret
jihad in that way other people will go
the other way and they'll say no no
jihad means purely this spiritual self
over kidding no it also does mean holy
war it means both of these it means
everything in between and being struggle
and struggle can take all these
different forms so it runs the gamut
from that and then book starts talking
about how how Muslims of Daft in life in
the United States so what are what are
some of the issues that would make
things not impossible but difficult so
diet is one of these Islam like
traditional Judaism forbids the eating
of park and there's a lot of other
little you know rules about what is
allowed to the city as a matter of fact
if you can't find a halal that is
acceptable designated you know place to
eat place to buy your food one
substitute for that is kosher
designations so Muslims you know well
sometimes by kosher products if they
can't find things that are actually
designated as long finding time for
evening prayer can be an issue as well
as a matter of fact again to talk about
indiana state prison when I was teaching
there this praying five times a day
sometimes it would that would occur
during class time and we were told not
to let the students out for that I never
you know prevented that mo to say you're
going off to go to the bathroom let them
do it in part because I didn't want to
impose a burden on that but you know
this could be a real issue if you're in
a workplace where you can't leave you
know American society do not adapt it to
that sort of thing borrowing and lending
of money at interest is forbidden in
Islamic law so what would that rule out
yeah
yeah there are dar ways around this you
know there are lending agencies but
they're not allowed to charge interest
there are those all sorts of other
things that they'd have to do but think
about this how many of you have these I
thought this particular one you know
Chris how dependent on are you in our
current economy on the use of credit
cards they're awfully convenient aren't
they now imagine you know strictly
speaking this is involving lending and
interests isn't it even if you get it at
zero percent interest for the
introductory offer you know blah blah
blah blah blah never stays that way so
this would be something that would
constitute a major obstacle there are
you know there are some some places
where believe it or not they don't take
cash anymore or checks just credit cards
that way that could be an issue some of
the other things that come up are
sexuals general traditional Muslim
culture is pretty male centered women
you have a much smaller role it varies
from country to country interestingly
when I would teach this in world
religions I would bring in photographs
of Muslim women in different countries
and you know places like Saudi Arabia
you're going to see grown women covered
from from top to bottom and it's not
going to be different colors it's all
gonna be black part in Afghanistan you
know under the Taliban you have the
burkas but the burgers might actually be
very different color some of them quite
pretty interesting other cases just a
headscarf some other cases no no
covering at all it varies depending on
on the the culture and the country quite
a bit but there is still some sort of
version of you know male roles and
female roles being being separate from
each other generally to the disadvantage
of women what else do we need to to hit
upon I'm going to skip over some of the
discussion about the structure of
mosques well i do want to point out one
thing in this chapter zone that your
book talks about is a distinctively
American probably also fostering
innovation and that's Islamic community
centers you can find these it in most
large cities and what is the purpose of
these well again Islam is you know in
certain ways like like Orthodox Judaism
like some more traditional forms of
Christianity it's an all-encompassing
way of life so it's not like just going
off to you know save prairies at the
mosque on Friday and then you know
everything else is anything goes the way
it is for some Christians on going to
church on Sunday and then it's got no
connection to the rest of your life in
North American Muslims need a variety of
institutional supports educational
facilities so I'm like you know I'll
think about sunday school in the role of
Sunday School recreational facilities is
there to create a sense of community as
a minority religious group intent on
preserving values and traditions and
this brings us to something that's
really interesting about marriage in
Islam so you know if you think about
where you're going to find Islam in the
world and let's put aside the westford
for the moment you know so we're not
talking about North South America or not
about Europe where else are we going to
find puzzles lots of my hands yeah like
North Africa mm-hmm North Africa so what
we often call us a care in Africa what
ethnicity other people are going to
Africa quite a few items because the
arrogant only spread out concrete a lot
of places for what else yeah yeah and
and Islam just spread it to what we call
sub-saharan Africa as well so Nigeria is
you know largely Muslim to the north and
largely Christian in the south and it's
been that way for for quite some time
with your Ruby non-traditional Yoruba
religion sort of scattered mostly in the
south because because as long has been
recently more hostile to that so black
you know Africans in Nigeria Torres you
know mauritania let's simply start going
through their East yeah yeah so we have
blazed who are ethnically distinct from
Pakistanis or ethnically distinct from
the bengalis in Bangladesh myself
bangladesh in Burma Muslims are actually
being persecuted by the majority
Buddhists their Burmese Muslims where
else from the middle east of course
right and a lot of Arabs in the Middle
East but a lot of other ethnicities as
well yeah yeah sort of an inheritance of
the ones who are still Muslim Lee after
the Communists of that in charge for a
long time but you know Kosovo you know
these these places that used to be in
the Ottoman Empire also all the stones
you know as an ox tongue pierced on
you know these these these Don Nations
those mostly converted to Islam at one
point or another usually under mondal
rules so you know if you go to an
Islamic community center you're going to
see a lot of different ethnicities one
of the majority of Congress in America
what would ethnic group did they come
from Americans who were already here on
the ground not immigrants who converted
to Islam african-american and not just
you know say Nation of Islam were more
science temple which are not considered
Orthodox but Sunni Islam the American
Muslim mission that was founded you know
really what the Nation of Islam has such
turned into what we know as the Nation
of Islam now as a lawsuit of that that's
been a lot about beach so there's going
to be a lot of diversity in any sort of
vomit community present today if your
book talks about some of the divisions
in Islam but it does it in very sort of
you know big picture thumbnail ways so i
will to mention it just because these
are terms that are useful to go but
don't don't take what we're doing here
is in any way an exhaustive study of
these these divisions so the biggest
division in islam is between Sunni and
Shiite and Sunni are by far the majority
of you know Muslims in the world about
eighty-five percent of Muslims worldwide
are Sunni Muslims there are differences
between different legal schools there's
four main legal schools that influences
practice there's differences between you
know the way Islam's lived out in
particular areas but for the most part
you can you can say that there's there's
you know one large not entirely modulus
you know can
community the Shiites have always been a
minority the split between them took
place almost you know immediately you
could say within the wholesome community
after the death of Muhammad because the
split had to do with who should be in
charge who should be the Khalif the
successor to the prophet and she had
held out for somebody who is actually
related to him so they wanted this guy a
lead to be his successor and Sunni
settled on another guy Abu Bakr and they
went to war with each other and you know
usually when you're the smaller side of
the war how do you do too well right and
the Shiite found themselves getting
getting pushed out they were able to you
know every once in a while sure to take
control but for the most part they have
been sort of pushed into the margins of
the the Islamic world they didn't take
over you know for example Iran Iraq is
is largely majority Shiite at least in
the you know parts that are ethnically
era a you know you'll find them in a few
other places there they're divided into
a couple different groups the twelvers
the seminars another is the Druze the
Druze are a very small group that are in
the mountains of Lebanon they're
considered heterodox by everybody else
and we could add to this you know some
of the other groups in America like the
Nation of Islam or more science temple
that are considered to be heterodox as
well another thing that that the Shiites
really emphasize is is martyrdom you'll
see them having passion plays for
example commemorating the death of aldi
and his his sons then your book also
talks about something else that I don't
want you to mix up is like being a third
group Sufi ism Sufism if one is a Sufi
this is the more ascetic practice within
Islam and traditionally was it was a was
Brotherhood's as a matter of fact most
of north africa south of the Sahara was
mission eyes by sufis likewise for
Central Asia they carried out a lot of
outreach you could say that had
incredible historical effects now to be
a Sufi means to take the five pillars
very seriously so seriously in fact that
you might do more than regular Muslim so
whereas you know every Muslim is going
to say pray five times a day sufis may
pray 50 times a day where as one might
recite the Shahada once they may recite
it continuously whereas it's only a
comment upon Muslims to fast during the
month of Ramadan sufis make fast there
and tell your wife restrict that you
know go without food altogether but
restrict the intake of food and drink
what else do we need to to talk to Joe
you know I guess the thing to close on
911 was real catalyst in many respects
most Americans probably do almost
nothing about Islam before nine eleven
imperfect as most Americans know almost
nothing about most religions and most
people we suffer from what we call
religious illiteracy and so that's sort
of thrust it into the mainstream and
suddenly experts were on TV talking
about Islam getting all sorts of
contradictory things it's a religion of
war it's a religion of peace you know
this is what it means this is what it
means and Americans can become I would
say in general
at least by my observation somewhat
better informed about the in the nature
of Islam over the last you know what is
it now 13 years but only marginally so
it's also provoked a lot of self
scrutiny within the American Muslim
community you know the question was well
at all who do you side with the other
thing that really provoked that feels of
course the invasion of Iraq in Iraq war
which by some was seen as a sort of war
on Islam so in your book talks about
this is a process of collective
self-definition address and consciously
the issues of how they're perceived not
only by outsiders but by themselves so
American Islam is something that's like
a lot of these groups that we've studied
in process it's not something that you
know we can make predictions about what
it's going to look like 50 years from
now here's one guaranteed prediction
will be more Muslims here in the united
states now that then there are now but
it's very difficult to predict with any
sort of certainty exactly where things
are going to go they're probably not
going to look exactly the same as they
do now anymore that now looks similar to
say 1970 so that's it for Islam